When people ask me what my favorite episode of 99% of Espoir's, I have a hard time answering, not because they're all my precious little babies or some such nonsense, but mostly because I just can't remember them all, and there's no simple criteria to judge them against each other. But the show I want to play for you today is definitely in contention for the best episode we've ever made. It just has everything, engaging storytellers, brilliant reporting, and a compelling history of a moment when the world really changed.
当人们问我最喜欢《99% Invisible》的哪一集时，我很难回答。这并不是因为它们都是我的心头肉之类的废话，主要是因为我记不住所有的节目，而且也没有简单的标准来衡量它们。但我今天要播放的这一集，绝对是我们制作过的最棒的节目之一。它应有尽有：引人入胜的讲述者、精彩的报道，以及一段关于世界真正改变时刻的动人历史。
It's called the Freedom House Ambulance Service. It originally aired in the summer of 2020, when a lot of the fundamental aspects of work, life, health, law enforcement, structural racism, cities, they were all being questioned by more and more people because of COVID and the George Floyd protests. Kevin Hazard, who reported this piece, subsequently released a whole book on Freedom House called, American Silence, the incredible story of the black men who became America's first paramedics. It is new, it is out now, you should buy it, you should read it, it should be on all your Christmas lists, it's incredible.
它叫《自由之家救护服务》（Freedom House Ambulance Service）。它最初于2020年夏天播出，当时由于新冠疫情和乔治·弗洛伊德抗议活动，工作、生活、健康、执法、结构性种族主义和城市等许多基本方面正受到越来越多人的质疑。报道此事的凯文·哈扎德（Kevin Hazard）随后出版了一本关于“自由之家”的完整书籍，名为《美国沉默：成为美国首批急救医生的黑人男性的不可思议的故事》（American Silence）。这本书是新的，现已上市，你应该买它，你应该读它，它应该出现在你所有的圣诞愿望清单上，它太棒了。
To celebrate the book's release, I'm proud to represent to you the remarkable story of the Freedom House Ambulance Service. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Back in the 1960s and 70s in the city of Pittsburgh, there was a nickname for guys like John Moon, the unemployed. We simply meant that no matter where you went for a job, nobody would hire you. Moon grew up in Pittsburgh's largely black and economically depressed hill district. In better times, the hill had its own neuro-league baseball team and jazz clubs that hosted Duke
为了庆祝这本书的发布，我很荣幸向大家介绍“自由之家救护服务”的非凡故事。这里是《99% Invisible》，我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。回到20世纪60年代和70年代的匹兹堡市，像约翰·穆恩（John Moon）这样的人有一个绰号，叫“不可雇佣者”。我们的意思很简单，无论你去哪里找工作，都没人会雇佣你。穆恩在匹兹堡大部分是黑人且经济萧条的希尔区（Hill District）长大。在更好的时期，希尔区有自己的黑人联盟棒球队和爵士俱乐部，接待过杜克·
Hellington and Louis Armstrong. But by the time Moon was graduating high school in the late 1960s, there was no escaping the neighborhoods, unemployable stigma. The reputation was there, but I don't want to go to the Hill because you may get beat up. You have drug addicts and alcoholics, and the same label was placed on myself, and I understood that.
艾灵顿（Duke Ellington）和路易斯·阿姆斯特朗（Louis Armstrong）。但到了20世纪60年代末穆恩高中毕业时，他已经无法摆脱社区那种“不可雇佣”的污名了。那种名声就在那里，我不想去希尔区，因为你可能会被打。那里有吸毒者和酗酒者，同样的标签也贴在了我身上，我理解这一点。
But just because that was your thought, doesn't necessarily mean that I had to live up to it. So Moon was glad to land a well-paying job right at a school at the local steel mill, only to discover that the hours weren't as reliable as he had hoped. Next he was in orderly at Pittsburgh's Presbyterian University Hospital, which provided steady employment, but not much else. All I was doing was making beds and taking people back and forth to the operating room and lifting and stuff like that, mechanical things where you didn't have to think.
但仅仅因为那是你的想法，并不意味着我必须活成那样。所以穆恩很高兴能在当地的钢铁厂找到一份薪水不错的工作，却发现工作时间并不像他希望的那样稳定。接下来，他在匹兹堡长老会大学医院当护工，这提供了稳定的工作，但仅此而已。我所做的只是铺床、把病人送进送出手术室、搬运东西之类的机械活，根本不需要动脑子。
For a while, Moon tried his best to find meaning in the work. But there was a part of me that said there has to be something more that I can do. Then one night, halfway through the graveyard shift, Moon watched as two men burst through the doors of the hospital. They were working desperately to save a dying patient. And as they rushed by, Moon stood pressed against the wall and wondered, Who are these people? What are they doing? How do they get to be able to do that?
有一段时间，穆恩尽力在工作中寻找意义。但我内心深处有一个声音说，我一定能做更多的事情。然后有一天，在深夜班进行到一半时，穆恩看到两个男人冲进医院大门。他们正在拼命抢救一名垂死的病人。当他们匆匆经过时，穆恩紧贴着墙壁想：这些人是谁？他们在做什么？他们是怎么学会做这些的？
Maybe today he wouldn't bet an eye at this scene, but in 1970 nothing about it made sense. The two men weren't doctors and they weren't nurses, and their strange white uniforms weren't hospital issue. But these guys came in with a certain type of confidence that was just shocking to me from the very point that they came into the room. And they had an emblem on their breasts that just picked my interest. The emblem was the two snake to caduceus, the traditional sign of medicine and healing. But just below the familiar symbol was a word John Moon had never seen before. Paramedic. Moon wasn't familiar with the term paramedic,
也许今天他不会对这一幕多看一眼，但在1970年，这一切都说不通。这两个人不是医生，也不是护士，他们奇怪的白色制服也不是医院发的。但这些人走进房间时带着一种令人震惊的自信。他们的胸前有一个徽章，引起了我的兴趣。徽章上是双蛇杖，这是医学和治愈的传统标志。但在熟悉的符号下方，有一个约翰·穆恩从未见过的词：急救医生（Paramedic）。穆恩不熟悉“急救医生”这个词，
because back then, no one was. That's reporter Kevin Hazard. Moon was witnessing the birth of a new profession, one that would go on to change the face of emergency medicine. But to Moon, perhaps the most striking thing of all, was that these first ever paramedics looked like him. I'm standing here looking at these two guys, and I'm saying to myself, my god, these are black guys.
因为那时没人知道。那是记者凯文·哈扎德。穆恩正在见证一个新职业的诞生，这个职业将改变急救医学的面貌。但对穆恩来说，最令人震惊的或许是这些首批急救医生看起来和他一样。我站在那里看着这两个人，心里对自己说：天哪，他们是黑人。
Never before had Munseen Young African-American men performing that kind of work. These were two guys that had afros in Beards, and the staff on the floor gave them a level of respect that amazed me. And there's something I never really mentioned to anyone. I actually snuck off of the floor and I actually followed them out to the vehicle because I wanted to see what prompted them to show such proudness and boldness. Once I looked at that vehicle, pull off,
穆恩从未见过年轻的非裔美国男性从事那种工作。这两个人留着爆炸头和胡子，楼层的医护人员对他们表现出的尊重让我感到惊讶。还有一件事我从未对任何人提起过。我实际上溜出了楼层，跟着他们到了车边，因为我想看看是什么让他们表现出那种自豪和大胆。当我看着那辆车开走时，
it was almost like, there goes my job. There goes my career, that's what I want to do. Moon vowed right then halfway through his long night shift to become a paramedic. Whatever that was. And in Pittsburgh in 1970 the only place to do that was an organization called Freedom House Ambient Service. So I went and applied to get a job with him and the rest is history. But that history about how a group of young black men from Pittsburgh became the world's first paramedics is still largely unknown. I'm a former paramedic myself. I did this job for 10 years
感觉就像是：我的工作在那儿，我的职业在那儿，那才是我想要做的。穆恩当时就在漫长的夜班中发誓要成为一名急救医生。不管那是什么。而在1970年的匹兹堡，唯一能做到这一点的地方是一个叫“自由之家救护服务”的组织。所以我去申请了他们的工作，剩下的就是历史了。但关于一群来自匹兹堡的年轻黑人男性如何成为世界上第一批急救医生的历史，至今仍鲜为人知。我自己也是一名前急救医生。我做了10年这份工作，
and you'd think the profession's origin story would be a big deal. But the truth is, most of the empties I've talked to have never heard of the Freedom House Paramedics, or understand what we owe them. Today, it's easy to take what paramedics do for granted. Call 911 and they'll arrive with cardiac monitors, airway equipment, and an array of pharmaceuticals to treat anything from heart attacks to gunshots to premature births. But for a long time, emergency medical service, or what today is called EMS, didn't provide anything resembling that.
你可能会认为这个职业的起源故事会是一件大事。但事实是，我交谈过的大多数急救人员从未听说过“自由之家”的急救医生，也不了解我们欠他们什么。今天，人们很容易把急救医生的工作视为理所当然。拨打911，他们会带着心脏监护仪、气道设备和各种药物赶到，治疗从心脏病发作到枪伤再到早产的各种情况。但在很长一段时间里，紧急医疗服务（即今天所说的EMS）并没有提供任何类似的服务。
In the early days of what we would view as EMS, it really wasn't the equivalent of what we see today. They would do whatever it was they knew to do, but you know, were they doing the right thing? Who knows? That's Richard Clinchy, he's the president of the EMS Museum and the trained paramedic. Clinchy says that when he started and emergency care in the late 50s, emergency services didn't provide treatment at the scene or even necessarily on a way to the hospital. They were just about getting you to the hospital as quickly as possible. Which kind of makes sense in a way it is after all where the doctors are.
在我们所认为的EMS早期，它确实不是我们今天看到的那样。他们会做他们知道该做的任何事，但你知道，他们做的是对的吗？谁知道呢？那是理查德·克林奇（Richard Clinchy），他是EMS博物馆馆长，也是一名受过培训的急救医生。克林奇说，当他在50年代末开始从事急救护理时，急救服务并不在现场提供治疗，甚至不一定在去医院的路上提供。他们只是想尽快把你送到医院。从某种程度上说，这很有道理，毕竟医生都在那里。
But as a result, it often wasn't clear whose responsibility it was to rush to the scene of an accident. Before the evolution of EMS, who did you call? Well, I was a paid firefighter back in the 60s and sometimes we got the call. If somebody needed a fire truck and they see it in New York, there were fireboxes everywhere. You'd pull the handle and a fire person on fire, but we would show up. In other areas, your responsibility for transporting patients often fell to local funeral homes. So imagine that you're having a massive heart attack, your life's in the balance and who rolls up to save you, two more tissions in a hurry.
但结果是，谁负责赶往事故现场往往并不明确。在EMS发展之前，你打给谁？嗯，我在60年代是一名带薪消防员，有时我们会接到电话。如果有人需要消防车，在纽约，到处都是火警箱。你拉动把手，消防员就会出现。在其他地区，运送病人的责任通常落在当地的殡仪馆身上。所以想象一下，你心脏病发作，生命垂危，谁来救你？两个匆匆忙忙的殡仪员。
But in many major cities, this crucial task fell to another municipal service that probably had even less business responding to medical emergencies. The police. In the area where I was a firefighter, we had a police department that had a 57 Chevrolet wagon. That was an emergency response vehicle. So the idea, the general public was faced with, it was more or less what I would call swoop and scoop,
但在许多大城市，这项关键任务落在了另一个市政服务部门身上，而他们处理医疗紧急情况的经验可能更少：警察。在我当消防员的地区，我们有一个警察局，有一辆57年的雪佛兰旅行车。那就是紧急响应车辆。所以，公众面临的想法，多多少少就是我所说的“俯冲和铲起”（swoop and scoop），
which simply meant that you'd call the police, that rushed the person out there to you, and then they'd pick you up, put you in the back and rush you back down to the hospital. With minimal training and equipment, John Moon's police departments could do little more than offer patients, basic first aid, a canvas stretcher, a half empty oxygen tank, and a pillow. Which more often than not, only serve to choke off the patient's airway. And on top of that, both individual, meaning police officers, got up front and left you back
意思很简单，就是你打给警察，他们冲过来，把你捡起来，扔进后座，然后把你送回医院。由于缺乏培训和设备，约翰·穆恩所在的警察局除了提供基本的急救、帆布担架、半空的氧气瓶和一个枕头外，几乎做不了什么。而这些东西往往只会堵塞病人的气道。最重要的是，两个警察都坐在前排，把你一个人留在后面，
there by yourself. So if you stop breathing by the time you arrived you were perhaps DOA because no one had done anything for you. The police simply didn't have the tools, the training, or the disposition to save people in a medical emergency. But in the absence of a dedicated emergency medical service, the job was being left to them by default. And perhaps nowhere was the problem of relying on the police for help, more vividly illustrated than in Pittsburgh's largely black hill district.
所以如果你在到达时停止了呼吸，你可能已经“到院死亡”（DOA），因为没人为你做任何事。警察根本没有工具、培训或意愿在医疗紧急情况下救人。但在缺乏专门的紧急医疗服务的情况下，这项工作默认留给了他们。而在匹兹堡大部分是黑人的希尔区，依赖警察寻求帮助的问题表现得最为生动。
Moon says the city's mostly white police force was often slow to respond to emergencies in the hill, or the black residents for their part were reluctant to even call the police to begin with. Because there was a trust issue with the police, primarily because there were no constraints. I mean, they could do whatever they wanted and there was no repercussion, consequences for their actions. No one wanted to get into the exact same police van that the cops had threatened to throw
穆恩说，该市大部分是白人的警察部队在希尔区处理紧急情况时往往反应迟缓，或者黑人居民本身就不愿报警。因为存在信任问题，主要是因为警察没有任何约束。我的意思是，他们可以为所欲为，而且没有任何后果。没人想坐进警察前一天威胁要把他们扔进去的那种警车里。
them in the day before. So there was issues all the way around. Do I really want to call the police? Chances are they're going to take their time getting here number one. And if I wait too long, then chances are a cap won't come to my neighborhood, primarily because of fear of being robbed or what the case says. So the options were very limited during that time. And the same was true to varying degrees in the rest of the country. Whether in neighborhood was served by the police, or the fire department, or the local funeral home,
所以到处都是问题。我真的想报警吗？第一，他们赶到这里很可能要花很长时间。如果我等太久，那么警察很可能不会来我的社区，主要是因为害怕被抢劫或者其他原因。所以在那段时间里，选择非常有限。在全国其他地方，这种情况在不同程度上也是如此。无论社区是由警察、消防部门还是当地殡仪馆提供服务，
so long as the priority was transportation, as opposed to treatment, no one even realized that there was a job that needed doing. But then, in the mid-60s, something happened which flipped the paradigm for emergency care on its head, and laid the groundwork for the invention of paramedicine. In 1966, the federal government published a white paper that would prove so influential that even now, in EMS circles, it is simply called the white paper. Basically, it told us we were killing over 50,000 people a year on the highways and doing so unnecessarily that there was a way to intervene and save those people. But we didn't have the people, nor the resources, nor the training to do a whole lot about
只要优先考虑的是运输而不是治疗，甚至没人意识到还有一项工作需要完成。但后来，在60年代中期，发生了一件事，彻底颠覆了急救护理的范式，并为急救医学的发明奠定了基础。1966年，联邦政府发布了一份白皮书，其影响力之大，以至于即使在今天，在EMS圈子里，它也被简称为“白皮书”。基本上，它告诉我们，我们每年在公路上有超过5万人死亡，而且是不必要地死亡，有一种方法可以干预并拯救这些人。但我们没有人员、资源或培训来做太多事情。
it. Techniques practice by combat medics overseas had been largely ignored by the medical community. With the result that a person was more likely to die of a gunshot wound in America than on a battlefield in Vietnam. The white paper shamed the government into providing money for EMS development on the local level. In government officials and local community leaders began searching for solutions, including a community organizer in Pittsburgh named Phil
海外战斗医护人员实践的技术在很大程度上被医学界忽视了。结果是，一个人在美国死于枪伤的可能性比在越南战场上还要大。这份白皮书羞辱了政府，使其为地方层面的EMS发展提供了资金。政府官员和社区领袖开始寻找解决方案，其中包括匹兹堡的一位社区组织者，名叫菲尔·
Halen. Oh my god, why do I do this? Halen is a former ambulance attendant who came to Pittsburgh in the early 60s and yes, he hates being interviewed. Okay, how long are we going to be going on this? I can't, I don't last very long at age 90. Halen ran is civil rights organization called the Maurice Falk Medical Fund,
哈伦（Phil Hallen）。天哪，我为什么要这么做？哈伦是一位前救护车服务员，60年代初来到匹兹堡，是的，他讨厌接受采访。好吧，我们要谈多久？我90岁了，坚持不了太久。哈伦经营着一个名为“莫里斯·福克医学基金”（Maurice Falk Medical Fund）的民权组织，
which examined health disparities due to institutional racism. And he immediately focused his eye on the city's pitiful emergency services. What was your impression of the level of care that was available on Pittsburgh? Well, it wasn't my impression of it. It was the way it was. You know, there was a dead-a-year level of care.
该组织调查了因制度性种族主义导致的健康差异。他立即将目光投向了该市可怜的紧急服务。你对匹兹堡可用的护理水平有什么印象？嗯，这不是我的印象，这就是事实。你知道，那是一种“一年死一人”水平的护理。
There was no such thing as emergency medicine or any of the things we know. Look back on it, I think, what the hell was going on. No, there was nothing. I mean, nobody was straight. Especially the cops. He could see that what was going on was effectively a public health crisis that was disproportionately affecting black neighborhoods. But then one day, Helen came across an article in the local paper about a black operated jobs training program based in the Hill District called Freedom House. The article described how Freedom House had rolled out a kind of mobile grocery store
根本没有所谓的急救医学或我们所知的任何东西。回想起来，我想，当时到底发生了什么？不，什么都没有。我的意思是，没人受过训练。尤其是警察。他看出正在发生的事情实际上是一场公共卫生危机，对黑人社区的影响尤为严重。但有一天，哈伦在当地报纸上看到一篇关于希尔区一个由黑人运营的就业培训项目“自由之家”的文章。文章描述了“自由之家”如何为黑人社区推出了一种移动杂货店，
for black neighborhoods using trucks to bring fresh vegetables to people's doors. And well, healthcare is terrible in the Hill District. We have to do something. If we could run a grocery van around, why can't we run a medical van around or something like that? Howland wasn't envisioning anything like modern emergency medical services. At first he just thought Freedom House's trucks could help transport people and underserved neighborhoods to the hospital and that they could hire people from
用卡车把新鲜蔬菜送到人们家门口。嗯，希尔区的医疗保健太糟糕了。我们必须做点什么。如果我们能开着杂货车到处跑，为什么不能开着医疗车到处跑呢？哈伦最初并没有设想任何像现代紧急医疗服务那样的东西。起初，他只是认为“自由之家”的卡车可以帮助将服务不足社区的人们送到医院，并且他们可以雇佣希尔区的人来驾驶这些车。但就在那时，我让大学医院的院长也加入了这个小组。
the Hill District to drive them. But that's when I got the director of the University Hospital on this group as well. And, you know, before the first meeting was over, he said, oh my God, we have to go immediately to SAFER. The experimental study you are about to see is one of 18 similar studies during which we compared various methods of artificial respiration. Dr. Peter SAFER was the head of anesthesiology at the University of Pittsburgh,
你知道，在第一次会议结束之前，他说，天哪，我们必须立即去SAFER。你即将看到的实验研究是18项类似研究之一，在这些研究中，我们比较了各种人工呼吸方法。彼得·萨法尔（Peter Safar）博士是匹兹堡大学麻醉学系主任，
and by that time, he was already famous in medical circles. Safr was a pure scientist and a very precise and impatient Austrian. We simulated field conditions by selecting as subjects men and women of various body types. This is a film of SAFER from 1951 demonstrating a new technique he developed for resuscitation. What today we call CPR. To help orient you, we have made a diagram of the experimental set up. SAFER understood that, to be effective, resuscitation needed to be started immediately by the first
到那时，他在医学界已经很有名了。萨法尔是一位纯粹的科学家，也是一位非常严谨且缺乏耐心的奥地利人。我们通过选择不同体型的人作为受试者来模拟现场条件。这是一部1951年萨法尔演示他开发的一种新复苏技术的影片。这就是我们今天所说的CPR。为了帮助你理解，我们制作了实验设置的图表。萨法尔明白，要有效，复苏必须由现场的第一个人立即开始，
person on the scene, but he faced heavy resistance from the medical community, which felt the general public couldn't be trusted with such specialized knowledge. So, SAFER performs an experiment. By anesthetizing and curing these subjects, we simulated limp asphyxia victims. SAFER paralyzed a group of volunteers using a chemical compound from the Amazon normally used on poison dip deros. It's just the same medical testing has changed a lot.
但他面临着医学界的强烈抵制，他们认为公众不能被信任掌握这种专业知识。所以，萨法尔进行了一项实验。通过麻醉这些受试者，我们模拟了瘫痪的窒息受害者。萨法尔使用了一种通常用于亚马逊毒箭的化合物使一组志愿者瘫痪。这只是说明医学测试已经发生了很大变化。
Once the volunteers could no longer breathe on the run, Safer had untrained lay people, UCPR, to keep those volunteers alive. And when I say untrained lay people, I mean children. This boy scout will perform mouth to airway breeding. Ultimately, saffers views would be vindicated. And for his effort, he'd forever be known as the father of CPR. Helen already knew some of this when he walked into Peter's saffers office in 1966. But nothing could have prepared him for what actually happened.
一旦志愿者无法呼吸，萨法尔就让未经训练的普通人使用CPR来维持这些志愿者的生命。当我说是未经训练的普通人时，我是指孩子。这个童子军将进行口对口人工呼吸。最终，萨法尔的观点得到了证实。由于他的努力，他将永远被称为“CPR之父”。哈伦在1966年走进彼得·萨法尔的办公室时已经知道了一些情况。但没有什么能让他为实际发生的事情做好准备。
Within seconds of greeting Helen and the Freedom House team, the Wierry and energetic saffer began to unleash a torrent of ideas. Basically, he said, you are just what I'm looking for. I've been trying to figure out how to take rescue breathing and the rest out on the street and to train people how to do that. You got the people. But Saffer didn't stop there. He wasn't content to just teach some van driver CPR. I said, let's go beyond that.
在问候哈伦和“自由之家”团队后的几秒钟内，精力充沛的萨法尔就开始倾泻出一连串的想法。基本上，他说，你们正是我们要找的人。我一直在想如何把救援呼吸和其他技术带到街头，并培训人们如何做到这一点。你们有人。但萨法尔并没有就此止步。他不满足于只教某个货车司机CPR。我说，让我们超越这一点。
Let's train them to be professionals as well. Professionals who could provide high quality medical care before the person was even taken to the hospital. It was not go to the scene, pick up a patient, transport to a hospital, and then start care. It was emergency treatment right there on the paper. Instead of repurposed cargo spaces, staffer argued that ambulances should be mobile intensive care units, staffed by professionals trained to use cardiac monitors, administer medication, and anything else that might keep a patient alive. Helen and the others could barely keep up.
让我们也把他们训练成专业人员。能够在病人被送往医院之前提供高质量医疗护理的专业人员。这不是去现场、接病人、运送到医院，然后开始护理。这是在现场进行的紧急治疗。萨法尔认为，救护车不应该是改装的货运空间，而应该是移动重症监护室，由受过培训使用心脏监护仪、施药以及任何其他可能维持病人生命技术的专业人员配备。哈伦和其他人几乎跟不上他的节奏。
Safer wasn't proposing a simple update to the existing system, but to change the whole culture of pre-hospital care. And he wanted to do it using Freedom House. I think somebody said, well, how big? What are we talking about here? He said, I can teach, I can remember this. I can instruct 40 people, and inside of a half an hour, we realized that there was something going on here,
萨法尔提出的不是对现有系统的简单更新，而是要改变院前护理的整个文化。他想利用“自由之家”来实现这一目标。我想有人问，规模有多大？我们在谈论什么？他说，我可以教，我记得这个。我可以指导40个人，半小时内，我们就意识到这里正在发生的事情，
which was way beyond anything that we had sought of. Stafford said about designing advanced ambulances, and an intense 300-hour course whose graduates would be the world's first comprehensively trained first responders. This wasn't just the birth of a profession, but of a whole new branch of medicine. It would become a vital link in the chain with a subculture all its own. In the world's first fully trained barometics would be stabbed exclusively with young black men from the hill district of Pittsburgh. And the people that worked there all were labeled unemployable. Freedom House recruited many of its first students right off the street, most of whom were
远远超出了我们所想的任何事情。萨法尔着手设计先进的救护车，以及一门密集的300小时课程，其毕业生将成为世界上第一批受过全面培训的急救人员。这不仅是一个职业的诞生，更是一个全新医学分支的诞生。它将成为链条中至关重要的一环，拥有自己独特的亚文化。而世界上第一批受过全面培训的急救医生将全部由来自匹兹堡希尔区的年轻黑人男性组成。而那里工作的人都被贴上了“不可雇佣”的标签。“自由之家”直接从街头招募了许多第一批学生，他们中的大多数人
just happy to land a good job, even if they were a little fuzzy on the details. John Moon wasn't part of that first class. He signed up a little later, but even he admits that, as incredible as he thought the opportunity was, he didn't fully understand what he was getting into. On some level, he was just excited to finally be wearing the uniform with the cool emblem that he saw on the first night. I'll put it this way. If someone bought you a thousand dollars suit
只是很高兴能找到一份好工作，即使他们对细节有点模糊。约翰·穆恩不是第一批学员。他晚一点才报名，但即使是他也承认，尽管他认为这个机会不可思议，但他并不完全了解自己要参与的是什么。在某种程度上，他只是很高兴终于穿上了他在第一晚看到的那个带有酷炫徽章的制服。我这样说吧。如果有人给你买了一套一千美元的西装，
and just gave it to you and said, just walk up and down the street at it, how would you feel? That's the way I felt. I was at the point where where okay, I got this uniform That's all it takes to help people and boy was I wrong It took a little bit more than that After they signed up moon and the others under what a battery of psychological evaluations and interviews with medical professionals
直接送给你，说，穿着它在街上走来走去，你会感觉如何？我就是那种感觉。我当时觉得，好吧，我有这套制服了，这就是帮助人们所需要的一切，天哪，我错了。这需要比那多一点的东西。在他们报名后，穆恩和其他人接受了一系列心理评估和专业医生的面试。
They learned anatomy physiology CPR advanced first aid nursing first aid, nursing, and defensive driving. At first, under SAFER, but later under Freedom House's first medical director, a 30-year-old white doctor with no previous ambulance experience named Nancy Caroline. And we look at her with skepticism because you have to remember she's not black. But once we found out that her heart was with us, that was really nothing she could do wrong. And everywhere she went, she took us with her. Caroline got the train needs access to almost every department of the hospital. She had them work in the morgue, the anesthesiology suite, and the maternity ward. And of course, if they were going to bring the ICU to the street,
他们学习了解剖学、生理学、CPR、高级急救、护理和防御性驾驶。起初是在萨法尔的指导下，但后来是在“自由之家”的第一位医疗主任——一位30岁的白人女医生南希·卡罗琳（Nancy Caroline）的指导下。我们带着怀疑的眼光看她，因为你必须记住她不是黑人。但一旦我们发现她的心和我们在一起，她就真的没什么做错的了。无论她去哪里，她都带着我们。卡罗琳让学员们能够进入医院的几乎每个部门。她让他们在太平间、麻醉室和产房工作。当然，如果他们要把ICU带到街头，
they had to master everything that happened in an ICU. So that included spinal immobilization, cervical immobilization, IV insertion, and the advantages of classroom training for us at that particular time is we would learn a procedure in class, or she would teach it to us, and then we would go out a half hour, 45 minutes later after we got out of class and performed that procedure on a person. In Freedom House paramedics, we're often the first people to perform that procedure outside of a hospital. They were among the first to use narcan to reverse an overdose and the first to save a patient by shocking their heart in the field. Moon told me that the biggest first he personally experienced came in a call where Nancy Caroline was riding along.
他们必须掌握ICU中发生的一切。所以这包括脊柱固定、颈椎固定、静脉注射，而当时课堂培训对我们来说的好处是，我们会在课堂上学习一个程序，或者她会教给我们，然后我们在下课半小时、45分钟后就会出去，在一个人身上执行那个程序。“自由之家”的急救医生通常是第一批在医院外执行该程序的人。他们是第一批使用纳洛酮（Narcan）逆转过量用药的人，也是第一批通过在现场电击心脏来挽救病人的人。穆恩告诉我，他个人经历的最大的“第一次”是在一次南希·卡罗琳随行的出诊中发生的。
It was a patient having trouble breathing. He was unconscious. So Moon started calling it in. where Nancy Caroline was riding along. It was a patient having trouble breathing. He was unconscious. So Moon started calling it in, but then Nancy Caroline stopped him. And law and behold, she said, start an IV and intubate this patient. And I said, repeat that.
那是一个呼吸困难的病人。他昏迷了。所以穆恩开始呼叫。但随后南希·卡罗琳阻止了他。瞧，她说，开始静脉注射并给这个病人插管。我说，请重复一遍。
So say, start an IV'll be an inter-baited dissipation. Moon thinks he was the first paramedic who has ever asked to innovate someone in the field. I wasn't able to confirm that, but innovation, the subtle but critical art of snaking a breathing tube into a patient's trachea is an incredibly difficult procedure. I've gone through the training.
所以她说，开始静脉注射并给这个病人插管。穆恩认为他是第一个被要求在现场进行插管的急救医生。我无法证实这一点，但插管——那种将呼吸管插入病人气管的微妙但关键的艺术——是一个极其困难的程序。我经历过这种培训。
It's not easy, even in a hospital setting. And here they were doing it on the sidewalk. Moon says you've scared to death. And once I gathered my nerves together, and remembered how she had taught us in the anatomy lab, I went ahead and did it. And once I interviewed the person taught us in the anatomy lab, I went in and I did it. And once I interpreted the person
即使在医院环境下也不容易。而他们当时是在人行道上做这件事。穆恩说你吓坏了。一旦我鼓起勇气，记住了她在解剖实验室教我们的方法，我就继续做了。一旦我给那个人插了管，
and took him to the emergency room, I had to deal with the ER doctor saying, well, who, who, who, who caused them to be interpreted? And I said, I did. And you are, I said, well, my name is John Mullen, and I'm a paramedic at Freedom House evidence service. But it wasn't enough for Moon and the other paramedics to simply master the techniques required for emergency medical care. Freedom House personnel faced an even bigger
并把他送到急诊室，我就得应付急诊室医生问：“好吧，谁，谁，谁，谁让他插管的？”我说：“我做的。”“你是谁？”我说：“我叫约翰·穆恩，我是‘自由之家’救护服务的急救医生。”但对于穆恩和其他急救医生来说，仅仅掌握急救护理所需的技术是不够的。“自由之家”的人员从接到电话的那一刻起就面临着更大的
challenge from the moment they got the call. The city had contracted with Freedom House to handle calls in Pittsburgh's mostly black neighborhoods in the downtown area. But the Pittsburgh police dispatchers often refuse to send them. Because the police looked at us as someone taking their jobs away, but Freedom House looked at the police as being a threat to the patient. And one of the things that we had to put in place is we use a police scanner. things that we had to put in place is we use a police scanner and we would monitor the calls and we would subsequently try to get to the scene before they did. Moon recalls getting to the scene just seconds after the police arrived and seeing them
挑战。该市与“自由之家”签订了合同，负责处理匹兹堡大部分黑人社区和市中心的电话。但匹兹堡的警察调度员经常拒绝派他们去。因为警察把我们看作是抢他们饭碗的人，但“自由之家”把警察看作是对病人的威胁。我们必须采取的一项措施是使用警察扫描仪，
try to drag patients out of wreck cars. And here we are saying no you can't do this Let's put them on a spine board and put a cervical collar on them. But remember, these were a bunch of black guys from the hill lecturing mostly white cops. You know, and we're yelling at them. And they're cussing us out. Sometimes the police would relent. But other times they would threaten the paramedics with arrest unless they backed off. And you know, the only thing you can do is just stand back and say, okay, and then you watch them drag the individual out of the car and put them in the back of a paddy wagon
我们会监控电话，随后尽量在他们之前赶到现场。穆恩回忆说，在警察到达几秒钟后赶到现场，看到他们试图把病人从失事车辆中拖出来。而我们在这里说：“不，你不能这样做。让我们把他们放在脊柱板上，戴上颈托。”但请记住，这是一群来自希尔区的黑人小伙子在教训大部分是白人的警察。你知道，我们在对他们大喊大叫。而他们在咒骂我们。有时警察会让步。但其他时候，他们会威胁要逮捕急救医生，除非他们退后。你知道，你唯一能做的就是退后说：“好吧”，然后看着他们把那个人从车里拖出来，扔进警车的后座，
and both guys get up front and they race off to the hospital. So those were oftentimes battles that you were not going to win. And it wasn't just the cops who didn't understand. Patients couldn't fathom why Moon was using a cardiac monitor and starting IVs in their house instead of hurrying them to a doctor. Their idea was let's call the ambulance. The ambulance comes to pick you up and take you to the hospital. That's all they knew. And it wasn't the easiest thing in the world to explain to a family member that we have
两个警察都坐在前排，飞驰向医院。所以这些往往是你赢不了的战斗。而且不仅仅是警察不理解。病人们无法理解为什么穆恩在他们家里使用心脏监护仪和进行静脉注射，而不是急着把他们送到医生那里。他们的想法是：打给救护车。救护车来接你，把你送到医院。他们只知道这些。向家庭成员解释我们已经把急诊室带到了病人身边，并不是世界上最容易的事情。
brought the emergency room to the person. Trying to convince white patients to submit to treatment was especially difficult. Some wouldn't even let the black paramedics touch them. That was found upon on more than one occasion, where they would say, no, do you have to really do this? I would prefer that you not do it. And it's something that we had to endure, because the problem was not with us. The problem was with the patient. It was their belief, their preconceived notion about the individuals that were touching them.
试图说服白人病人接受治疗尤其困难。有些人甚至不让黑人急救医生碰他们。这种情况不止一次发生，他们会说：“不，你真的必须这样做吗？我宁愿你不要这样做。”这是我们必须忍受的，因为问题不在我们。问题在于病人。这是他们的信仰，他们对接触他们的个人的先入为主的观念。
The same went for doctors and nurses at any hospital not directly affiliated with SAFER and the Freedom House program. Moon remembers trying to read a patient's vital signs, only to have a nurse laugh in his face as if he was pretending to play doctor. Other Freedom House paramedics were mistaken for orderlies and asked to mop the floor. But despite all the struggle, Freedom House's reputation was growing. People were beginning to recognize that something really different was going on here. This wasn't just called the ambulance. Phil Hallen says stories started to spread about an ambulance service that could perform
对于任何不直接隶属于萨法尔和“自由之家”项目的医院的医生和护士来说也是如此。穆恩记得他试图读取病人的生命体征，却被一名护士嘲笑，好像他在假装扮演医生。其他“自由之家”的急救医生被误认为是护工，被要求去拖地。但尽管困难重重，“自由之家”的声誉正在增长。人们开始意识到这里正在发生一些真正不同的事情。这不仅仅是叫救护车。菲尔·哈伦说，关于一种能够在可怕事故现场执行
miraculous life-saving procedures at the scene of horrific accidents. Perhaps the most influential story was about a kid on his bike who was hit head-on by a car. The accident was in Squirrel Hill, one of the city's most affluent neighborhoods, and one that freedom house had never been allowed to enter. So initially, the dispatcher sent the police, but the cops panicked. The kid was bleeding out in front of them, and they had no idea what to do.
奇迹般救生程序的救护服务的报道开始传播。也许最有影响力的故事是关于一个骑自行车的孩子被车正面撞倒。事故发生在松鼠山（Squirrel Hill），这是该市最富裕的社区之一，也是“自由之家”从未被允许进入的社区。所以起初，调度员派了警察，但警察慌了。孩子在他们面前流血不止，他们根本不知道该怎么办。
And somebody said, get Freedom House up here. And they did a miraculous activity, which nobody had ever seen, and they'd take place on the street before. People watched it happen, and that was a major turning point. By this time, Freedom House's five ambulances were running nearly 6,000 calls a year and providing demonstrably better care.
有人说：“把‘自由之家’叫来。”他们做了一项奇迹般的活动，这是以前没人见过的，而且是在街上发生的。人们看着它发生，那是一个主要的转折点。到那时，“自由之家”的五辆救护车每年处理近6000次呼叫，并提供明显更好的护理。
At a City Council meeting, SAFER presented data showing that as many as 1,200 people a year had been dying needlessly while in the care of other emergency services. Freedom House paramedics, by contrast, had saved 200 lives in the first year alone. Doctors and medical directors from around the country flocked to Pittsburgh. Freedom House medics were invited to conferences as far away as Germany. Everyone wanted to see what they were doing
在市议会会议上，萨法尔展示了数据，显示每年有多达1200人在其他紧急服务的护理下不必要地死亡。“自由之家”的急救医生相比之下，仅在第一年就挽救了200人的生命。来自全国各地的医生和医疗主任蜂拥至匹兹堡。“自由之家”的医护人员受邀参加远至德国的会议。每个人都想看看他们在做什么，
and learn how they could copy it. And in 1975, the federal government chose Freedom House to field test the first standardized training curriculum for EMS providers. Nancy Caroline was asked to write the textbook. But Freedom House's growing reputation would ultimately prove to be its greatest liability. The more successes they charted up, the more certain residents and city officials wanted to see Freedom House gone. And according to John Moon, it was for a simple reason. How dare you have an EMS system or an ambulance service
并学习如何复制它。1975年，联邦政府选择“自由之家”来实地测试第一个标准化的EMS提供者培训课程。南希·卡罗琳被要求编写教科书。但“自由之家”日益增长的声誉最终被证明是它最大的负担。他们取得的成功越多，某些居民和城市官员就越想看到“自由之家”消失。据约翰·穆恩说，原因很简单：你们怎么敢拥有一个EMS系统或救护服务，
this good serving the black economically deprived community or as society says those people and we don't have anything like that. And perhaps no one did more to punish freedom house for this transgression than Pittsburgh's mayor. Elected in 1969, 45-year-old Pete Flerty was a fiscally conservative Democrat. Tall and broad-shouldered, he went into office already believing programs using taxpayer money should be managed entirely by the city. But ask Phil Hallen, and he'll tell you he believes that the mayor's beef with Freedom House went beyond issues of fiscal or bureaucratic turf. What was his opinion of Freedom House?
服务于黑人经济贫困社区，或者正如社会所说的“那些人”，而我们却没有这样的东西。也许没有人比匹兹堡市长更严厉地惩罚“自由之家”的这种“越轨”行为了。1969年当选的45岁的皮特·弗莱厄蒂（Pete Flaherty）是一位财政保守的民主党人。他身材高大，肩膀宽阔，上任时就认为使用纳税人钱的项目应该完全由城市管理。但问问菲尔·哈伦，他会告诉你，他相信市长与“自由之家”的矛盾超出了财政或官僚地盘的问题。他对“自由之家”有什么看法？
Well, I didn't like it particularly, because it was doing too well, that was black. You think that's why he felt that way? I think so. Was it your opinion that he was racist? Yes. When Flaherty took office, he slashed Freedom House's operating budget in half. This didn't leave enough money to cover even routine maintenance on the ambulances. Caroline repeatedly wrote frustrated missives to Freedom House's board complaining about
嗯，他特别不喜欢它，因为它做得太好了，而且是黑人的。你认为这就是他那样感觉的原因吗？我想是的。你认为他是种族主义者吗？是的。当弗莱厄蒂上任时，他将“自由之家”的运营预算削减了一半。这甚至不足以支付救护车的日常维护费用。卡罗琳多次写信给“自由之家”的董事会，抱怨
breaks and steering that locked up, doors that fell from the hinges and seats that toppled over. Once, according to Caroline, an engine caught fire while transporting a patient. Flirty passed an ordinance that banned ambulances from using their sirens in certain neighborhoods, which significantly slowed their response times. And I first I'll say you can't use a siren downtown because people are complaining about it.
刹车和转向锁死、门从铰链上掉下来、座椅翻倒。据卡罗琳说，有一次，引擎在运送病人时着火了。弗莱厄蒂通过了一项法令，禁止救护车在某些社区使用警笛，这大大减慢了他们的响应时间。起初我说你不能在市中心使用警笛，因为人们在抱怨。
Unfortunately, people look in the vehicle to see who's driving it and then they complain. So we're going on the calm down town and you have to blow your horn to tell the car to get out of the way. And they're looking at you like you're crazy. Rumors were spread that Freedom House paramedics were selling drugs and running dice games from the ambulances, and that thousands of dollars had been stolen from headquarters. And it became a struggle after struggle, after struggle and eventually, you know, it's almost like a patient struggling to breathe and eventually the heart gets tired and it
不幸的是，人们往车里看，看是谁在开车，然后他们就抱怨。所以我们去市中心时，你必须按喇叭告诉车让开。他们看着你，就像你疯了一样。有谣言称“自由之家”的急救医生在救护车上卖毒品和玩骰子游戏，总部被偷走了数千美元。这变成了一场又一场的挣扎，最终，你知道，这就像一个病人挣扎着呼吸，心脏最终疲惫了，
stops beating and the person stops breathing and that's exactly what happened. In 1975, Flerdy struck a final devastating blow. He announced that the city would roll out its own brand-new paramedic service. Not only was the new service showered with resources Freedom House had long been denied, its recruits were all white. The city needed Caroline to serve as its medical director
停止跳动，人停止呼吸，这正是发生的事情。1975年，弗莱厄蒂发出了最后致命的一击。他宣布该市将推出自己的全新急救医生服务。新服务不仅获得了“自由之家”长期被拒绝的资源，而且其新兵全是白人。该市需要卡罗琳担任其医疗主任，
and she used that leverage to make one demand that the Freedom House crews be hired on. Flaherty Relented, sort of. Because the city was required to bring the employees over but they were not required to keep them. So they found a way to get rid of them. So you know, that's how the city's system ended up being 98% quite when the first EMS system in this country
她利用这一筹码提出了一个要求：雇佣“自由之家”的团队。弗莱厄蒂让步了，算是吧。因为城市被要求接收这些员工，但他们并不被要求留住他们。所以他们找到了摆脱他们的方法。所以你知道，这就是为什么当这个国家第一个EMS系统是
was African American. Within a few years of being replaced by the city's EMS service, Freedom House was more or less forgotten. In part because like all good things, paramedics were soon taken for granted. Today it never occurs to anyone to ask where paramedicine came from. But to Phil Hallen, that's the true measure of freedom house's legacy. Paramedicine is just there.
非裔美国人时，城市的系统最终变成了98%的白人。在被城市EMS服务取代后的几年内，“自由之家”或多或少被遗忘了。部分原因是像所有美好的事物一样，急救医生很快就被视为理所当然。今天，没人会想到问急救医学是从哪里来的。但对菲尔·哈伦来说，这就是“自由之家”遗产的真正衡量标准。急救医学就在那里。
You know, do you know anybody that doesn't take this for granted at this point in any American city or even in the American countryside. I mean, nobody would even think of a time when somebody would not survive because they couldn't, that somebody didn't know how to do CPR. It's unthinkable anywhere in the United States. The model of care created at Freedom House ended up being adopted by countless other paramedics programs across the country, very often with the help of Freedom House veterans. Peter Safr helped develop a paramedic program in Baltimore. Mitchell Brown, another Freedom House alum, became the EMS Commissioner for the City of Cleveland
你知道，在任何美国城市甚至美国乡村，你知道有谁不把这视为理所当然吗？我的意思是，没人会想到一个时代，有人因为没人知道如何做CPR而无法幸存。这在美国任何地方都是不可想象的。“自由之家”创建的护理模式最终被全国无数其他急救医生项目所采用，通常是在“自由之家”老兵的帮助下。彼得·萨法尔帮助开发了巴尔的摩的急救医生项目。另一位“自由之家”校友米切尔·布朗（Mitchell Brown）成为了克利夫兰市的EMS专员。
and later its Director of public safety. In Nancy Caroline founded the first ever EMS service in Israel. Her textbook titled Emergency Care in the Streets ended up setting the standard and EMS instruction for decades. As for Moon, he stayed with Pittsburgh EMS and retired in 2009 as an assistant chief. How does he feel about it all now? When he looks back on the days when a handful of young men from the Hill made history. It's something that I'm extremely, extremely proud to have been a part of. And every time I see an EMS unit going down the street,
后来担任了公共安全局局长。南希·卡罗琳（Nancy Caroline）在以色列创立了有史以来第一个急救医疗服务（EMS）系统。她编写的教科书《街头急救护理》（Emergency Care in the Streets）在随后的几十年里成为了急救医疗教学的标准。至于穆恩（Moon），他留在了匹兹堡急救中心，并于2009年以助理局长的身份退休。他现在对此有何感想？当他回想起当年那群来自希尔区（Hill）的年轻人创造历史的日子时，他说：“我为自己能参与其中感到无比、无比自豪。”每当我看到一辆急救车驶过街道，
I wonder, do they have any idea that's where it all began because it all began there. Kevin and I discuss what lessons the surprisingly recent history of paramedicine might offer people contemplating a different role for police in our public safety infrastructure today after this. This interview with Kevin Hazard was recorded in July of 2020. Okay, so I'm now talking with Kevin Hazard who reported that story for us. And you are a paramedic. I think that's interesting to know. How did you get into being a paramedic?
我都会想，他们是否知道这一切是从哪里开始的？因为一切确实始于那里。凯文和我将讨论，这种令人惊讶的、近在眼前的急救医学历史，能为今天正在考虑改变警察在公共安全基础设施中角色的人们提供什么启示。本次对凯文·哈扎德（Kevin Hazard）的采访录制于2020年7月。好的，我现在正在和为我们报道这个故事的凯文·哈扎德交谈。你本身也是一名急救人员，我觉得了解这一点很有趣。你是怎么成为一名急救人员的？
Basically after 9-11 I was working as a reporter and You know a lot of my my friends had been in the military and they had these crazy stories that they would tell one of them was among the first Marines to enter into Iraq You know and he's like crazy stories that they would tell. One of them was among the first Marines to enter into Iraq. And he's cruising along and talking about rockets, being fired from a helicopter so close, he could feel the heat off of them. And I'm sitting in city council meetings and reporting on whether or not they should put speed bumps
基本上在9·11事件之后，我当时是一名记者。你知道，我的很多朋友都参过军，他们会讲一些疯狂的故事。其中一个人是第一批进入伊拉克的陆战队员之一。你知道，他讲的故事太疯狂了。他当时正开着车，谈论着从直升机上发射的火箭弹，离他如此之近，以至于他能感觉到火箭弹散发的热量。而我当时正坐在市议会会议上，报道他们是否应该在郊区的街道上设置减速带，
in various suburban streets. And I was just frustrated and bored. And in one night, I got sent by my editor to cover a tunnel collapse. They were doing this huge infrastructure project in Atlanta. There were six guys on a scaffolding that dropped 250 feet into the earth, and we sat outside with the families and waited. There were group of paramedics that went down there, the high-angle rescue team, and they repel down to the darkness and we're all waiting and waiting and waiting and finally they emerge.
我感到既沮丧又无聊。一天晚上，编辑派我去报道一起隧道坍塌事故。他们当时在亚特兰大进行一项巨大的基础设施工程。有六个人在脚手架上，结果坠落到250英尺深的地下。我们和家属们坐在外面等待。有一组急救人员下去了，那是高角度救援队，他们垂降进入黑暗中，我们都在不停地等待，最后他们终于出现了。
Of course, the news is as bad as we anticipated it to be. But there was something in those guys in the way that they carried themselves and whatever it was that they saw once they disappeared into darkness of that whole, I just thought, whatever version of the truth that I'm looking whole, I just thought, whatever version of the truth that I'm looking for, I think those guys are carrying it somewhere within them. And so I just signed up for an EMT class completely on a lock, and no idea if I even could finish it. And next thing, I'm sitting on an ambulance and I'm my way to some ridiculous call. It all happens somewhat accidentally.
当然，消息和我们预料的一样糟糕。但那些人身上有一种特质，以及无论他们在消失进那个洞穴的黑暗中后看到了什么，我当时就想，无论我在寻找什么样的真相，我想那些人身上一定带着某种答案。于是，我完全凭运气报名参加了一个急救员（EMT）课程，根本不知道自己是否能坚持下来。接下来，我就坐在救护车上，正赶往某个离谱的现场。这一切发生得有些偶然。
Yeah. I mean, it sounds pretty similar to the story that John Moon says, you know, like of sees someone being inspired of that as being a vocation and that speaking to you in some way. Did that story have particular resonance with you because of your own experience? Yeah, it did. I mean, if you get to the heart of John's story, you know, really he's a young guy who's looking for a way to prove himself in the world, you know, a particular two-world that has ignored him. You know, obviously my experience in life is vastly different from John's. But, you know, that, to me, it was, I saw this group of people who were doing something that I thought that I could do. You know, it didn't feel like an unattainable goal, but it felt
是的。我的意思是，这听起来和约翰·穆恩（John Moon）说的故事很像，你知道，就像看到某人受到启发，将其视为一种使命，并以某种方式触动了你。那个故事因为你自己的经历而对你产生了特别的共鸣吗？是的，确实如此。我的意思是，如果你深入了解约翰的故事，你会发现他其实是一个年轻人，正在寻找一种在世界上证明自己的方式，在一个曾经忽视他的世界里。显然，我的人生经历与约翰大不相同。但是，对我来说，我看到了这群人正在做一些我认为我也能做的事情。你知道，这感觉不是一个遥不可及的目标，但它感觉
like this incredible opportunity to do this sort of thing that I never anticipated. It didn't feel like an unattainable goal, but it felt like this incredible opportunity to do the sort of thing that I never anticipated, to have the opportunity to do. So there was a lot in John's story that always rang true to me. And what part of your career did you learn about this history about the first paramedics being Black men from an underserved neighborhood in Pittsburgh, and this whole word since during. No part. I think that's probably the reason that, you know, John sits up at night, you know, filing his teeth and his, and his, his Pittsburgh home. Nobody knows this. When, When I went to paramedic school, my instructor was one of the first six medics
就像是一个绝佳的机会，去做那种我从未预料到自己能做的事情。所以约翰的故事中有很多内容总是让我产生共鸣。你是在职业生涯的哪个阶段了解到这段历史的——关于第一批急救人员是来自匹兹堡服务不足社区的黑人男性，以及整个“自由之家”（Freedom House）的故事？从来没有。我想这可能就是为什么约翰晚上坐在匹兹堡的家中，独自磨牙的原因。没人知道这件事。当我上急救学校时，我的导师是佐治亚州最早的六名急救员之一，
in the state of Georgia. And he was telling us these stories of the early days when he was riding a horse coming out of the funeral homes and they would embombodize one night and then transport the next. And he did get a call and he sweep the flower petals out of the back of the horse and you rush off.
他给我们讲了早期的故事，那时他骑着马从殡仪馆出来，他们晚上负责防腐处理，第二天负责运送。他接到电话后，把马车里的花瓣扫掉，然后就匆忙出发了。
So when you say sweeping out petals in the hearse, he was one of those people sent by the funeral home to be an EMS person. Is that what you mean? Yeah, and much of Atlanta, the only people who were at capable of transporting a body with a funeral home. Right? They have how many people have something like a hearse. And so he was a funeral home employee.
所以当你提到清扫灵车里的花瓣时，他是殡仪馆派来做急救工作的人员之一吗？你是这个意思吗？是的，在亚特兰大的大部分地区，唯一有能力运送遗体的人就是殡仪馆。对吧？有多少人会有灵车之类的东西？所以他是一名殡仪馆员工。
And one night a week he would embombodize. And then the next night he would be responsible for responding to emergency calls. And this was, you know, before there was any notion of a paramedic. So these guys had, you know, maybe 10 hours of first-aid training. And they're sitting down, you know, in the basement of the funeral home. Call comes in, they rush out. Again, they yank out. The casket sweep out the flower petals, slide in some sort of a stretcher, and then race the streets in a hearse, which he's old Cadillac hearse, and he said that if you got going too fast, the brakes would soften up and you couldn't stop.
他每周有一个晚上负责做防腐处理，第二天晚上就负责响应紧急呼叫。这还是在没有任何“急救人员”概念的时候。所以这些人可能只有10个小时的急救培训。他们坐在殡仪馆的地下室里，电话一响，他们就冲出去。同样，他们把棺材拉出来，扫掉花瓣，滑进某种担架，然后开着灵车在街上狂奔。那是老式的凯迪拉克灵车，他说如果开得太快，刹车就会变软，根本停不下来。
So there's screaming, there's hearse with a purple light on its roof, screaming through the city of Atlanta with no brakes. Flower petals trailing out of the back window. Oh my goodness, that sounds like a totally different world. It's amazing that that's within our lifetimes. That's just amazing. It's not that long ago, at all. Yeah. Yeah. And so hearing these stories of the early days when they carried a credit card machine with them and before they dropped a patient off the hospital, they'd slide it in front of them and say, cash checker
所以，一辆车顶闪着紫灯的灵车，在亚特兰大市里尖叫着狂奔，却没有刹车。花瓣从后窗飘落。天哪，这听起来完全是另一个世界。令人惊奇的是，这竟然发生在我们有生之年。这太不可思议了。这其实没过多久。是的。是的。听到这些早期的故事，他们随身带着信用卡机，在把病人送到医院之前，他们会把机器滑到病人面前说，付现金还是刷卡？
charge. You know, this really sort of wild west era in which nobody really knew what they were doing. But that was all I knew about it was that it started out in a very, you know, slip shot sort of way and then slowly became serious. It wasn't until after my book came out that somebody said to me, hey, there's another story, another EMS story if you're ever looking for one,
你知道，这真的是一个狂野的西部时代，没人真正知道自己在做什么。但我所知道的全部就是，它以一种非常草率的方式开始，然后慢慢变得严肃起来。直到我的书出版后，才有人对我说，嘿，如果你还在找故事的话，还有另一个急救医疗的故事，
and it was said in Pittsburgh. And so I started googling it, and the only thing I could find were a handful of local press accounts, of these young men and women who had done this thing in the late 60s and early 70s, and I started digging into it and all of a sudden The reality of what it was that it happened that nobody knew
它发生在匹兹堡。于是我开始在谷歌上搜索，我能找到的只有少数几篇当地媒体的报道，讲述了这些在60年代末和70年代初做这件事的年轻人。我开始深入挖掘，突然间，那段没人知道的真实历史浮出水面。
You know, I know a paramedic from Pittsburgh who has no idea that this was the start of it all and for no one to know that It was who was shocking to me Particularly something who did it for a year and wrote about it You know, that's when I got in touch with John and I said, how does nobody know this? And he just screamed, I know, nobody knows. Oh, I'm so glad that we get to tell a story because it's amazing to me. And it's it's pretty resonant today. And particularly the role of police in both the story that you told and what's happening right now, there's this history there that we presented that is, you know, the police were the kind of default
你知道，我认识一个匹兹堡的急救人员，他根本不知道这一切是起源于那里。没人知道这件事让我感到震惊，尤其是对于一个从事过一年并写过相关报道的人来说。你知道，那时我联系了约翰，我说，怎么会没人知道这件事？他只是大喊，我知道，没人知道。哦，我很高兴我们能讲述这个故事，因为它对我来说太神奇了。而且它在今天非常有共鸣。特别是警察在你讲述的故事和现在发生的事情中所扮演的角色，我们呈现的那段历史中，警察是这类紧急情况下的默认
person to be called in this type of emergency, even though they had, you know, no skills or inclination to do the job that was required. And we're looking at what policing means today. And what does it mean that a person potentially armed like a soldier is brought to a situation where someone has stroke, for example, and maybe that isn't the right thing to do. And we had this discussion, you know, or we, you know, like people had this discussion, you know, in the late 60s and 70s too. So when you think about the story you told in your experience and you think about what the discussions are happening today, how do you take in the moment and reconcile it
呼叫对象，尽管他们没有任何技能或意愿去完成所需的工作。我们正在审视今天的警务意味着什么。如果一个像士兵一样武装的人被带到有人中风的现场，这又意味着什么？也许这并不是正确的做法。我们在60年代末和70年代也进行过这样的讨论。所以，当你思考你讲述的故事和你的经历，再看看今天正在进行的讨论时，你是如何看待当下并将其与我们讲述的这段历史相调和的呢？
with this history that we told in this story? Yeah, what's crazy about that is when I began researching this story, I was coming across quotes that really got to the heart of a conversation we're just now having today. And these are things that I was reading in the fall and spring of 2018 and 2019. You know, the early medics who were out there saying, Hey, you know, if you want this police truck to show up at your house, you have to understand that last night, that was a truck that showed up to arrest your neighbor. And tomorrow night might be the truck to show up to rest you. And if you really
是的，最疯狂的是，当我开始研究这个故事时，我发现了一些真正触及我们今天正在进行的对话核心的引语。这些是我在2018年秋季和2019年春季读到的东西。你知道，早期的急救人员在外面说，嘿，如果你想让这辆警车出现在你家门口，你必须明白，昨晚，这辆车是去逮捕你邻居的。而明晚它可能就是来逮捕你的。如果你真的
think people are going to be comfortable calling that guy to arrive tonight, then you don't think you understand the situation we're living in. And there was a lot of pushback from the city of Pittsburgh, Allegheny County about changing this system because it was the system that had always been and people thought, well, it works. And somebody was able to come along and prove that no, this isn't working. And these guys aren't suited for this task. No, but I think what is valuable
认为人们会乐意今晚叫那个人来，那你就不了解我们所处的环境。匹兹堡市和阿勒格尼县对改变这个系统有很多阻力，因为这是长期以来的系统，人们认为，嗯，它运作得很好。但有人能够站出来证明，不，这行不通。这些人并不适合这项任务。不，但我认为历史教训的价值在于，
about these lessons of history, it's so recent that paramedics were invented. You know, like it's so surprisingly recent that it should free your mind to think of the possibilities of what an infrastructure of public safety could be today if we didn't all want its arrest on the police and wanted to try something different. I would agree I
急救人员的出现是如此之近。你知道，这令人惊讶地近，它应该解放你的思想，去思考如果今天我们不把公共安全基础设施全部押在警察身上，而是想尝试一些不同的东西，那会是什么样子。我同意，我
understand the resistance to it. I understand the fear that people feel when you say something like defund the police it sounds like a really radical term. But if you can sit down and realize how often the police are called out because there's a psych patient who hasn't taken his medicine and his 76 year old parents aren't certain what to do with them. And this police officer shows up, you know, not saying to a hammer, everything looks like a nail. Well, you know, unfortunately, the police really kind of they have, they're limited in terms of what they can do. And one of the things I learned very quickly in doing that job was that the police can't lose a fight.
理解对它的抵触。我理解当你说“削减警察经费”时人们感到的恐惧，这听起来是一个非常激进的词。但如果你能坐下来意识到，警察被叫去处理心理病人是因为他没吃药，而他76岁的父母不知道该怎么办，这种情况有多频繁。然后警察出现了，你知道，就像拿着锤子的人，看什么都像钉子。嗯，你知道，不幸的是，警察确实，他们在能做的事情上是有限的。我在做那份工作时很快学到的一件事是，警察不能输掉一场冲突。
You know, by the nature of their profession, they are, their back is against the wall. And once they arrive, they have to keep pushing forward. And oftentimes, that led to a situation that didn't need to happen. You know, what could have been a situation that we had deescalated, wound up escalating because the person that arrived with someone who had essentially, if they didn't get cooperation, they only had one avenue that they could venture down. It's amazing to me to think, you know, when John Moon saw the paramedics for the first time,
你知道，由于他们职业的性质，他们背水一战。一旦他们到达现场，他们就必须继续推进。而往往这导致了本不该发生的局面。你知道，原本可以通过降级处理的情况，却因为到达现场的人本质上如果得不到配合，就只有一条路可走，最终导致了升级。想到约翰·穆恩第一次看到急救人员时，我感到非常惊讶，
he'd never heard the word paramedic, you know, and it was completely novel to most people. And I'm thinking today about How we're thinking about the police and maybe how to sort of you know defund them or divest them of some of these activities Which they're not suited towards I think it's kind of interesting to imagine that there could be a word you know that is like a Rapid response social worker, mental health worker, that is going to be sent out to people
他从未听说过“急救人员”这个词，你知道，这对大多数人来说是全新的。我今天在想，我们是如何看待警察的，也许是如何去，你知道，削减他们的经费或剥离他们不适合从事的某些活动。我觉得想象一下有一个词，你知道，比如“快速反应社会工作者”、“心理健康工作者”，被派往人们那里，
that will be a word like paramedic in 50 years. I mean, you thought about that? It feels like we're on the cusp of that moment. There's no doubt that people are looking for a new way for police to respond. It's something different to come out and the number of instances we've had in which you know These situations have gone wrong how often it has been someone who's called out for a mental health issue or something
在50年后会像“急救人员”一样成为一个常用词，这很有趣。我的意思是，你想过这个问题吗？感觉我们正处于那个时刻的边缘。毫无疑问，人们正在寻找一种新的警察响应方式。这是某种不同的东西，考虑到我们发生过多少次这些情况出错的案例，有多少次是有人因为心理健康问题或其他原因被叫去处理，
It didn't initially appear to be a crime in progress and you have to think that somebody out there and amidst all these You know defund the police conversation someone someone must be saying, well, how else can we in deploy these resources? Who else can we bring to bear in these situations? I can bring a better outcome. And there's probably a new job title, a new role, a whole new group of people that are sitting out there that not too long from now, we're all going to look back and say, well, of course, it's so obvious, you know, naturally, those guys are there, naturally,
最初看起来并不是正在发生的犯罪。你必须认为，在所有这些关于“削减警察经费”的对话中，一定有人在说，好吧，我们还能如何部署这些资源？在这些情况下，我们还能带来谁？我可以带来更好的结果。可能有一个新的职位名称，一个新的角色，一大群新的人，不久之后，我们所有人都会回过头来说，好吧，当然，这太明显了，你知道，自然而然地，那些人就在那里，自然而然地，
those people are responding. How in earth did we live without them? And I, you know, I think we're sort of at the moment where these things are born. Well, I think it's really interesting and I'm so glad we're able to share this story. So thanks so much for talking with us and for reporting. That's been great. Thank you. It's really great to be here. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Kevin Hazard, edited by Joe Rosenberg, mix and tech production by Sarah McCarthy and Sheree Fusef, updated mixing by Martin Gonzales, music by Swan Rihall, our senior editor is Delaney Hall, Cris Boreaux, is the digital director, the rest of the team,
那些人在响应。我们没有他们是怎么活过来的？而且，你知道，我认为我们正处于这些事物诞生的时刻。嗯，我认为这非常有趣，我很高兴我们能分享这个故事。非常感谢你与我们交谈并进行报道。这太棒了。谢谢。能来到这里真是太好了。《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）本周由凯文·哈扎德制作，乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）编辑，萨拉·麦卡锡（Sarah McCarthy）和谢丽·富塞夫（Sheree Fusef）负责混音和技术制作，马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzales）更新混音，音乐由斯旺·里霍尔（Swan Rihall）创作，我们的高级编辑是德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall），克里斯·博罗（Cris Boreaux）是数字总监，团队的其他成员，
is Vivian Leigh, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Chris Baroubaix, Jason D'Aleon, Bosh Maudon, Kelly Prime, Jacob Moltenado Medina, Sophia Klatsker, intern Olivia Green, and me Roman Mars. Kevin Hazard's book about the Freedom House Ambulent Service that goes into much more depth and detail is called American Silence, the incredible story of a black man who became America's first paramedics. You should get it. We'll have a link in the show notes. We are part of the Stitcher and Series XM podcast family. Now headquartered at Six Blocks North in the Pandora building. And beautiful.
是薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、克里斯·巴鲁拜（Chris Baroubaix）、杰森·达莱昂（Jason D'Aleon）、博什·莫顿（Bosh Maudon）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、雅各布·莫尔特纳多·梅迪纳（Jacob Moltenado Medina）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker），实习生奥利维亚·格林（Olivia Green），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。凯文·哈扎德关于“自由之家”救护服务的书，深入探讨了更多细节，书名叫《美国沉默：黑人成为美国第一批急救人员的不可思议的故事》（American Silence, the incredible story of a black man who became America's first paramedics）。你应该买来看看。我们会在节目说明中提供链接。我们是Stitcher和Series XM播客家族的一部分。现在总部位于潘多拉大楼（Pandora building）北六个街区。在美丽的，
Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 999PI orc. We're on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99 PI at 99pion.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@999PIorg。我们也在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上。你可以在99pion.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及《99%隐形》的每一集往期节目。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。